у фільмі то ними промови путіна
автори показала якона я внесу розвалу
джини та more easy організації тралік та
на блошиних до кремля політики спливаючи
на граматику думку заходу
д показати їм і рідше кремля батька і
дезінформації вербова не її вина в
інтернеті та фінансова петренко права у
європі унікально німецькому телебаченню
бананове ті кого думаю з фільм поруч
вітри та черга біля sand and окупантів наук
рф та берлін кремлівської пропаганди
авдеїв перші місця зйомки стілець і тіні
зморшки всім його серце не збитися
стартував автопробіг замір берлін москва
будучи його варити цитата на зло жінка
анексію криму та вину в Україні люди q3
сюди прийшли
вірити в тисячу росія завмер автори фільму
називається прикладом того ж російська
пропаганда проти джессел про
кремлівського лобі у європарламенті
Тетяна жданок депутат до європарламенту
зла тві іванів худий до фракції золотих
чому часто голосуючи проти своїх
колег і за політику кремля, наприклад,
вона виступала про те санкції ще до
росії хто ж за на і коштувати з я пхав
автори фільму та вдома будувати кадри зняті
висловив 2009 уроки незадовго до вибору
до європарламенту
tagged океану чеканок Петро іншого в
георгій мурадів до верона особливо путіна та
aqua явно журналісти за його дар вченням
на одному із заходи за участь зинке
політика при суть не моторам роздавав
та по 3000 рублів німецької провінції
кремль Петро і мої права міс тачку бен
ганн на заході не матчі на ісу стригти
молодіжного крила правого популістські
партії альтернатива для них чини при
сотні та лідер про путінську руку
об'єднаний молодіжний фронт
кремль Петро маючи правих у не манчіні
дамон будувати автори фільму донбас
кремль героя сепаратистами автори фільму
так вже проаналізували 10000 або Стів
за електронною поштою так дзвонова
міністра інформації днр з рідним до zip
ще до роботи змі а також стратегія
внутрішньої та інформаційної політики
журналіста називаю сім'я 1 за 2
документа олександр козаків
заступник директора центру політичного
кон'юнктури офіс компанії знаходиться в
Москві
сайті в казан ще виноски про через
адміністрацію президента Росії
Санкт-Петербург
кремлівські тролі у санкт-петербурзі
автори фільму взяла інтерв'ю у Віталія
які раніше гидко так за ванну
фабрику тролів на вулиці Савушкіна 55
вина розпорошив protect роль з творити
негативний образ
україни то заходу в інтернеті автори
фільму називають їх воїнам м і режим столітті
пара чують на замовлення кремля